- [Instructor] We have other videos
on individual techniques
for factoring quadratics,
but what I would like to do in this video
is get some practice figuring out
which technique to use, so I'm gonna write
a bunch of quadratics, and I encourage you
to pause the video, try to see if you can
factor that quadratic yourself before
I work through it with you.
So the first quadratic
is 6x squared plus 3x.
So pause and see if you can factor this.
So this one might jump out at you
that both of these terms
here have a common factor.
Both of them are divisible by three,
six is divisible by three and so is three,
and both of them are divisible by x,
so you can factor out a 3x.
So if you factor out a 3x, 6x squared
divided by 3x, you're gonna
have a 2x left over there
and then 3x divided by 3x,
you're going to have a one.
And that's about as much as we can
actually factor, and you can verify
that these two expressions are the same
if you distribute the 3x,
3x times 2x is 6x squared,
3x times one is 3x, and
that's all we would do.
We would be done.
That's all you can
really do to factor that.
And as we'll see, in this example,
trying to factor out a common factor
was all we had to do, but as we'll see
in future examples, that's
usually a good first step.
Do all of, check whether the terms
have a common factor, and if they do
it never hurts to factor that out.
So let's do another example.
Let's say I have the quadratic
4x squared minus 4x minus 48.
Pause the video and try to
factor that as much as you can.
Alright, so the first thing
you might have noticed
is that there is a common
factor amongst the terms.
All of them are divisible by four.
Four is clearly divisible by four
and 48 is also divisible by four.
So let's factor a four out.
This would be the same thing as four
times x squared minus x minus 12.
I just divided each of these
by four and I factored it out.
You can distribute the four and verify
that these two expressions are the same.
Now are we done?
Well no, we can factor what we have
inside the parentheses, we
can factor this further.
Now how would we do that?
So over here the key realization
is alright, I have a one as a coefficient
on my second degree term.
I've written it in standard form
where I have the second degree and then
if there's a first degree term,
and then I have my constant term
or my zero degree term, and if I have
a one coefficient right over here
then I say, okay, are there two numbers
whose sum equals the coefficient
on the first degree term, on the x term,
so are there two numbers
that add up to negative one?
You didn't see a one here
before but it's implicit there.
Negative x is the same
thing as negative 1x.
So are there two numbers, a plus b,
that is equal to negative one and whose
product is equal to negative 12?
This is a technique that
we do in other videos,
and here the key is to realize that hey,
maybe we can use it here.
So a times be is equal to negative 12.
And there's a couple of
key realizations here.
It's like, okay, if I have two numbers
and their product is
going to be a negative
that means one of them, that means
they're gonna have different signs.
One's going to be positive and
one's going to be negative.
If they had the same sign
then this would be positive.
So let's think about the factors of 12,
and especially think about them
in terms of different sign combinations.
So you could think about one and 12,
and whether you're
thinking about negative one
and 12, negative one plus
12 would be positive 11.
If you went the other way around,
if you went negative 12 and
one it would be negative 11,
but either way that doesn't work.
Two and six, negative two and six
would be four, negative six and two
would be negative four,
so that doesn't work.
Three and four.
Let's see, negative three and four
would be positive one, but three
and negative four works out.
You add these two together, you take
their product, you clearly get negative 12
and then you add them
together, you get negative one.
So we can write inside the parentheses,
so let me write, so this is gonna be
four times, so we can factor
that as two binomials.
The first is going to be x plus,
the first is going to be x plus three
and then the next is going to be,
we could say x plus negative four
or we could say x minus
four, and we're done.
And if any of this seems
intimidating to you
I encourage you to watch the videos
on introduction to factoring polynomials.
The key here is to recognize the method.
So once again, at first try to
factor out any common factors.
We did that in both examples.
And then we saw here, hey if we have
a leading one coefficient here
on the second degree term and we have
it written in standard form, well let's
think of two numbers that add up
to this coefficient and whose product
is equal to the constant
term, and in this case
it was three and negative four,
we were able to factor it this way.
We prove that in other videos.
Let's do another example.
We can't get enough
practice, and like always,
pause the video and see if you
can work through it yourself.
Three x squared, plus 30, plus 75.
Alright, I'm assuming you had a go at it.
So you might immediately see that
all of the terms are divisible by three,
so let's factor three
out, so it's gonna be
three times x squared plus, oh whoops,
this should be an x here, my apologies.
Pause the video again and
see if you can do it (laughs)
now that I wrote the
actual right thing there.
So as you imagine it's nice to factor out
a three first, so it's
three times x squared,
plus 10x, plus 25, and so you might
immediately say alright, let's use
the technique we had here.
We have a leading one coefficient,
it's written in standard form.
Can I think of two numbers
that add up to ten,
so a plus b is equal to
10, and whose product,
a times b, is equal to 25?
And this would work.
And if you look at the factors of 25
you'd say, alright, well this thing here
is positive, this is positive,
so I'm dealing with two positive numbers
and to get 25 it's either a one and 25
or five and five, and
five and five match this.
Five plus five is equal to 10.
Five times five is equal to 25.
And so just using the exact technique
we just did, you'd say
okay this is three times
and the stuff in parentheses would be
x plus five times x plus five,
or you could say three
times x plus five squared.
So some of you might
have immediately said,
well I don't have to do
that exact technique.
I could have immediately recognized this
as a perfect square
because I have a square
constant right over here, and that's
a good sign that hey,
maybe I should explore
whether this is going to be
a perfect square polynomial.
So this is a perfect square, and if I were
to take the square root of
it, and this coefficient
is twice that square root, well that's
a good sign that I'm probably dealing,
or that I am dealing
with a perfect square.
But either way, whether you recognize it
as a perfect square or
whether you use the technique
that we used in the second problem,
either one of those would get
you to the appropriate answer.